c'est là préfèrent bonjour à tous merci
de me retrouver sur public sénat alors
que le gouvernement face aux critiques a
décidé d'ajourner à la mise en place
d'un nouvel acte de la décentralisation
il y aura d'ailleurs trois textes
distincts pour examiner cette nouvelle
réforme territoriale les sénateurs ont
adopté hier une proposition de
résolution à l'initiative du groupe ump
et qui vise à réaffirmer à l'attachement
du groupe ump ici au sénat à la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales à leur autonomie
financière mais aussi à la commune qui
doit rester selon eux est bien le pivot
central de l'organisation territoriale
de la france
alors sans plus tarder à direction
l'hémicycle pour revoir à cette séance
qui s'est tenue hier bonne latine à tous
la séance est reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle l'examen de la proposition de
résolution relative au respect des
droits et libertés des collectivités
territoriales présentée en application
de l'article 34-1 de la constitution par
monsieur jean claude gaudin et les
membres du groupe ump et apparentés et
rattachés dans le débat la parole est à
monsieur jean pierre raffarin groupe ump
auteur de la proposition de résolution
monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues la décentralisation est
une très belle aventure et son histoire
est inséparable de celle de la
république c'est pour ça que dans ces
moments incertains
c'est un beau sujet de réflexion
collective tous les républicains peuvent
se sentir à l'aise dans cette démarche
démocratique qui vise à rapprocher
l'élu de l'électeur jetons regard sur
l'histoire après les hésitations
légitime de la grande révolution
la décentralisation est devenue une
réalité sous la troisième république
avec monsieur longuet le programme de
nancy rédigé en 1865 à la fois par des
légitimistes
on se souvient de montalembert on se
souvient de fallou des orléanistes iso
et parrot des républicains comme ferrer
mais aussi et libéraux ce programme
proposé en particulier d'affranchir la
commune de la tutelle du préfet et de
diminuer les pouvoirs de ce dernier à
l'endroit du conseil général la loi
municipale de 1884 sera un facteur
décisif pour assurer la pérennité de la
république
dix ans après son rétablissement en 1869
les progrès de la décentralisation
légitime
l'apparition d'un nouveau concept la
déconcentration sous la quatrième
république pierre mendès-france esquive
à un projet qui deviendra un livre
régionaliste la république moderne
le fondateur de la vème république le
général de gaulle avant que la france ne
soit troublé par les agitations de 68 10
et pris position le 24 mars en déclarant
les activités régionales apparaissent
comme les ressorts de la puissance
économie
de demain jean-jacques servan-schreiber
et l'express ont promu le pouvoir
régional georges pompidou initiera
l'établissement public régional et
valéry giscard d'estaing libérera à
nouveau paris en lui donnant un statut
municipal de plein droit
françois mitterrand nivernais mais aussi
charentais avait sur ces sujets une
pensée très avancé la france dit il a eu
besoin d'un pouvoir fort pour ce faire
elle a aujourd'hui besoin d'un pouvoir
décentralisé pour ne pas se défaire
il y a trente ans laventure de la
décentralisation a franchi une étape
historique une onde de choc
ce fut l'acteur j'ai vécu cette période
décevante sur d'autres sujets avec
espérance au total j'ai adhéré à cette
réforme
à partir de 1986 j'ai vécu l'acte 1 en
acteur régional engagé est confiant 18
ans durant à la tête de l'exécutif de
poitou charentes j'ai pu mesurer le vent
frais qui avait été suscité par cette
réforme
avec mon ami le sénateur alain fouché
nous avons un vécu très heureux de la
décentralisation qui notamment dans
notre département était animée par le
président moh noces les lycées ont
changé dans la forme mais au total les
changements ou était profond pour les
collèges aussi le préfet devenu un
metteur en chambre le débat
territoriales à gagnant démocratie la
responsabilité financière a été assumée
l'administration territoriale a
considérablement était en progrès et
surtout ce qui me concerne ce qui est
très important c'est que les différents
échelons de notre république y compris
l'europe ont appris à contractualiser
ensemble et ce n'est pas le moindre
à qui ainsi cette étape de la
décentralisation a amené les acteurs à
jouer ensemble à partager les projets à
faire du contrat un véritable levier de
l'action commune je regrette que par la
suite les contrats de plan se soient
dispersées
je regrette aussi que le fait régional
était et profiter de cette situation
pour chercher à se définir en opposition
à l'état plutôt que de chercher à
prolonger l'action de ce dernier en
l'adaptant aux données territoriales en
france c'est clair
la région n'est pas une nation mais
seulement une part de la nation les
oppositions à sept acteurs 1 ont eu pour
effet positif de mon point de vue de
rassembler les girondins de droite et de
gauche
et ce n'est pas le moindre des mérites
de la décentralisation que de créer de
nouvelles convergences et de faire
bouger les lignes politiques
hélas les organes centraux des partis
politiques sont souvent à la fois des
professionnels et des praticiens de la
centralisation il faut le bon sens des
élus de terrain pourtant entend corriger
le tir soulignons cet esprit positif des
grands élus territoriaux qui était à
l'époque pierre mauroy et gaston
defferre et que soutenait rené monory
jacques chaban delmas
edgar faure jean françois poncet ces
avancées ont été prolongées par celle de
l'intercommunalité notamment sous
l'impulsion en 1999 du ministre d'état
ministre de l'intérieur qui était jean
pierre chevènement à matignon j'avais
convaincu le président chirac d'engager
l'acte 2 de la décentralisation au sein
de la majorité d'alors le sujet n'était
pas vraiment consensuel mais le
président m'a fait confiance et ainsi
nous avons prolongé
l'actos un en décentralisant les
personnels techniques des lycées
collèges les atos décentralisation
démission mais décentralisation haussier
des moyens nous avons engagé il ya
encore du travail
la clarification des compétences en
centrant la région sur les sujets de
stratégie économique et en focalisant le
département sur les exigences de
proximité le rôle de chef de file a été
instituée et nous avons réformé la
constitution pour y renforcer la
décentralisation
l'article 1 fixe notre engagement dans
le marbre
l'organisation de la république
française et décentraliser le principe
de subsidiarité est explicité avec le
nouvel article 72
les collectivités territoriales ont
vocation à prendre des décisions dans
l'ensemble des compétences qui peuvent
le mieux être mises en oeuvre à leur
échelon la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales et dans cet
article constitutionnaliser nous en fait
progresser le principe de l'autonomie
financière des collectivités
territoriales et la démocratie de
proximité a été renforcée notamment
grâce au référendum d'initiative qui
permet aujourd'hui la belle initiative
démocratique alsacienne nous connaîtrons
ainsi dans quelques jours la vérité sur
le conseiller territorial qui ainsi va
être en place le rôle du sénat comme
assembler des territoires a aussi été
renforcée cela lui donne autorité pour
corriger sur ce sujet les copies
gouvernementales successives
cela semble aujourd'hui d'actualité ce
vaste ensemble était donc constitutifs
de l'acte ii depuis la crise dans tous
les pays du monde à légitimer de
nombreuses mesures de recentralisation
par tous les plans de relance chez nous
en plus un grand emprunt l'êta a repris
la main sur de nombreux projets de
territoire la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle à protéger les finances
du bloc communal mais à limiter
l'autonomie fiscale des autres échelons
et enfin les allers retours de la
réforme territoriale risque de
déstabiliser l'organisation de nos
territoires
aujourd'hui l'acte iii de la
décentralisation est en préparation avec
quelques soubresauts
madame la ministre le moment est
opportun pour que le sénat rappelle les
principes essentiels auxquels il est
attaché pour que progresse en france
la république décentralisée la réforme
constitutionnelle récente nous en faire
une capacité nouvelle guinea sciatique
par l'apli
34,1 et la proposition de résolution
ce que le président godin le groupe ont
décidé de vous présenter aujourd'hui il
est ainsi pour nous opportun et
pertinent que la haute assemblée dans
son ensemble et dans sa diversité
rappelle l'essentiel de ses convictions
sur le sujet au moyen d'une résolution
le tout récent recul du gouvernement
montrent que l'exécutif semble toujours
à la recherche d'une ligne directrice
espérons madame le ministre que
l'éclatement du projet en plusieurs
textes n'aura pas été imaginé pour
masquer un manque de cohésion globale
la résolution qui vous est proposé
rappel les neuf principes qui nous
semble relativement consensuel au sein
de notre assemblée et qui pourrait
justement est une proposition de
cohérence pour l'ensemble de ces textes
qui tous ensemble réunis pourraient
constituer l acte iii de la
décentralisation
le texte que nous vous proposons
rassemble les grands actes qui de latin
et de l'acte 2 je les regroupe selon les
grands échelons de notre république
d'abord la connaît c'est l'essentiel la
commune doit rester au coeur du dialogue
territorial républicain le bloc communal
et le centre de la démocratie locale
l'exigence l'exigence de solidarité
d'une part mais aussi la capacité de
projets d'autre part s'exprime par
l'intercommunalité que nous préférons
collégiale plutôt que hiérarchique
pour cela la commune conserve la
compétence générale et par sa libre
administration peut en ministration
peut-on déléguer une partie à
l'intercommunalité voilà pour la commune
le département circonscriptions
sénatoriales et l'échelon de la cohésion
cohésion sociale mais aussi cohésion
territoriale en charge à la fois de
l'action sociale mais aussi de
l'aménagement
locales territoriales et notamment
rurales parce que le département exprime
la recherche de l' équilibre entre ces
territoires
le département est l'échelon le plus
près des collectivités territoriales les
plus fragiles c'est ma conviction
profonde et ça n'a pas toujours été
je le dis à cette tribune et j'ai eu
d'autres convictions dans le passé
qu'ils n'étaient pas si forte
quant à haut potentiel du département
mais c'est la crise de la ruralité qui
me rend aujourd'hui fondamentalement
départementaliste qui défend la ruralité
quand on voit de paris pense au grand
paris que l'europe est à peine lisible
que les régions pense aux métropoles qui
s'occupe des territoires ruraux
le département est le premier partenaire
de la ruralité qui veut défendre la
ruralité doit défendre le département
c'est le lieu de l'equilibre la commune
le département la région la région a
plus une vocation de stratégie que de
proximité
sa taille en france est très inégale
certaines régions ont la dimension
européenne et rayonne autour de leurs
métropoles régionales et souvent inter
régionale je peux vous dire que l'un des
bonheurs de la politique c'est de
connaître son pays dans les profondeurs
jeu l'occasion avec nos multiples
campagnes électorales de revisiter la
france quand vous allez aujourd'hui à
bordeaux sur les rives de la garonne et
de la gironde quand vous allez
aujourd'hui à fête des lumières à lyon
quand vous allez voir marseille capitale
culturelle quand vous allez à la
braderie à la braderie de lille
quand vous regardez nos grandes
métropoles interrégionale vous verrez
comme elles se sont embellies alors que
le monde entier aujourd'hui parlent de
la cité durable de la cité intelligente
regardez nos villes elles se sont non
seulement amélioré en valorisant leur
patrimoine
mais grâce au tramway et grâce au
développement urbain elles ont réussi à
mettre de la fluidité dans tous leurs
environs évidemment ces métropoles sont
très attractives quelquefois même elle
rendre jalouse leur région car leur
influence dépasse même ces territoires
et on voit bien avec la réussite des
métropoles fait quelquefois de l'ombre à
leur région mais ces salles ce sont les
grandes régions dans d'autres
territoires
la région n'a souvent que la puissance
équivalente d'un département
supplémentaires chez moi qu'à
département la région et ont fait un
cinquième département
son budget est inférieur au budget du
département le plus important et dans ce
cas la région a tendance à cantonaliser
son action est ainsi concurrence
chevauchement des doublons se
multiplient c'est je crois un point
important cette idée ne figure pas dans
notre résolution mais je vous la
communiquer ce que nous l'avons les uns
et les autres en commun au fond je crois
profondément que l'agrandissement de
certaines régions et donc le diminution
de leur nombre permettrait une meilleure
différenciation entre la région
stratégie et le département proximité et
de ce point de vue là il y à des
économies à faire et ce qu'ils
voudraient voir dans la décentralisation
qu'une logique de l'impôt nous donc il y
à des économies à faire des économies à
ce faire elles sont à faire notamment en
éliminant les chevauchements les
doublons et ceci peut se faire d'autant
plus facilement que les deux échelons
sont très différenciées l'un d'eux
dimension européenne pour la stratégie
économique
l'hôte de dimension plus le calme et
nationale pour la cohésion sociale et
territoriale l'état quant à lui l'autre
échelons naturellement essentielle qui
nous rassemble n'a pas avoir peur
les danses les décentralisateur ne sont
pas des fédéralistes
il souhaite que par la déconcentration
et l'aménagement du territoire
l'état soit un partenaire quotidien des
collectivités territoriales nous
aspirons à plus d'autonomie financière
pour plus de responsabilité à plus de
liberté pour plus d'initiatives à plus
de simplification pour agir plus vite et
mieux mais aussi à plus de péréquation
pour plus d'équité territoriale
nous aussi nous tous ici
nous sommes des militants mais aussi des
pratiquants du choc de simplification il
est possible pour tous de faire des
économies et de participer aux efforts
budgétaires mais la concertation qui a
été engagé droite est poursuivi pour une
grande rationalisation de l'action
publique
mes chers collègues les progrès
passeront toujours par un pacte national
des territoires les uns ne réussiront
pas contre les autres
ma dernière remarque si vous le
permettez et pour jeter un regard au
dehors de nos frontières
la décentralisation n'est pas un vieux
débat pour un vieux pays
regardez tous ces pays émergents
regardez tous ces pays qui connaissent
les meilleures performances pour eux
aussi
la décentralisation est un sujet de
cohésion nationale et de dynamique
locale la chine le brésil l'inde sont
aujourd'hui sur des réformes importantes
pour que les territoires puissent
s'exprimer avec force et même aussi
notre voisin allemand dont le modèle est
certes différent du nôtre mais dont les
territoires sont particulièrement
mobilisés et participent fortement à la
dynamique nationale
en conclusion mes chers collègues vous
verrez que cette proposition de
résolution cherche à nous rassembler
c'est une forme de rappel et de
d'adhésion aux grands principes de notre
démocratie locale
nous souhaitons réaffirmer
solennellement notre attachement à la
décentralisation à la libre
administration des collectivités alors
autonomie financière ainsi qu'à la
commune échelons centrale et pivot de
l'organisation territoriale de notre
pays
dans ce contexte nous affirmons notre
souhait de voir se mettre en place une
véritable et ambitieuse politique
équilibrée de tous les territoires de la
république
c'est pourquoi notre groupe le groupe
ump demandent au sénat la création d'une
mission d'information sur l'avenir de la
décentralisation au titre de l'article 6
bis de notre règlement afin que toutes
les sensibilités politiques puissent
travailler ensemble
sur un projet commun et au fond c'est
peut-être là le moyen pour le sénat
d'éclairer le chemin du gouvernement
cette mission nous permettra de proposer
une cohérence de pensée c'est ce que le
sénat doit faire il en a le devoir il en
a la capacité
dans un livre très récente les très
intéressant des rites julie il y a
trente ans l'acteur de la
décentralisation ou l'histoire d'une
révolution tranquille
la parole est donnée à de très nombreux
acteurs de la décentralisation est tous
dans ce livre un peu synthèse expriment
la même conviction que je vous prie de
bien vouloir partager aujourd'hui un
renouveau de la décentralisation
s'impose
je vous rappelle que la conférence des
présidents a décidé que les
interventions des orateurs valait
explications de vote dans la suite du
débat la parole est à monsieur gérard
larcher pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je ne reviendrai pas
sur l'histoire de décentralisation et de
la déconcentration jean pierre raffarin
l'a fait de manière remarquable
aujourd'hui nous proposons que le sénat
adopte manière un peu solennel parce que
à mon avis les temps mérite cette
solennité la proposition de résolution
présenté par notre collègue jean claude
gaudin au nom des sénateurs du groupe
ump
c'est un texte mes chers collègues sur
lequel nous pouvons ou plutôt nous
devons nous retrouver
j'allais d'erreurs dans notre diversité
politique
pourquoi tout simplement parce que nous
ne faisons rien de plus dans cette
résolution que de proposer au sénat ne
rappeler avec force la lettre et les
principes de notre constitution en
matière de respect des droits et des
libertés des collectivités territoriales
nous savons tous bien que les élus
locaux souhaitent que nous soyons
capables de nous retrouver sur des
sujets essentiels nous les sénateurs
avec le même esprit de l'intérêt général
que celui qui les anime dans leurs
assemblées locales c'est d'ailleurs ces
assemblées locales qui demeurent les
plus proches de nos concitoyens en ces
temps de crise d'interrogations et de
difficultés nous avons donc veiller à ce
que cette proposition de résolution qui
vous est soumise s'en tienne à demander
la stricte observance de la constitution
sans ajouter ni retrancher un principe
qui ne soient gravées dans son marbre et
j'aurais rappeler ses principes
l'organisation de la république est
décentralisée la libre administration
qui garantit qu'aucune collectivité
et ne peut exercer de tutelle sur une
hotte est un second principe l'autonomie
financière qui permet aux collectivités
de bénéficier d'une part significative
de ressources propres est aussi un de
ses principes ses principes d'éco les
règles auxquelles les sénateurs que nous
sommes ne peuvent que rappeler leur
attachement fondamental bourde ou pire à
l'heure raffarin le disait bien instant
un principe cardinal
la commune est l'échelon de base de
notre démocratie locale et rien ne peut
justifier la remise en cause
fondamentale de la commune pour nous
cela signifie au minimum trois choses la
commune est le pivot de l'organisation
et du dialogue territorial
parce qu'elle est le premier échelon de
proximité et de vie démocratique
la clause de compétence générale que
nous avons beaucoup évoqué dans cet
hémicycle qui lie à un peu plus de deux
ans et demi est un droit inaliénable de
nos communes qui garantit la réalité
territoriale de l'action publique
le développement de la coopération
intercommunal auquel nous réaffirmons
notre attachement et notre contribution
ne peut s'inscrire que dans le respect
du principe de subsidiarité
pourquoi éprouvons nous aujourd'hui le
besoin de rappeler ces principes qui
devraient s'imposer naturellement tout
simplement parce que nous sommes
inquiets nous sommes à quai parce que la
musique que je joue aujourd'hui le
gouvernement me paraît assez lointaine
de la partition que le candidat françois
hollande
présenté dans une vibrante plaidoirie
c'était déjà à dijon en faveur du
respect des collectivités territoriales
il y a aussi des déclarations de
principe en octobre dernier
en conclusion des états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale états généraux
qui avaient suscité l'attention des élus
locaux qui quelles que soient leurs
sensibilités politiques s'étaient
investis dans les différents ateliers
aujourd'hui la réalité apparaît peu à
peu au grand jour monkey dénonciez notre
réforme de la carte intercommunale qui
prévoyait je le rappelle un plancher de
5000 habitants c'était l'objet d'un
débat voilà que
nous proposait notamment dans la région
ile-de-france des opci de 300000
habitants au minimum pour la petite
couronne 200 milles au minimum pour la
grande couronne et à généraliser des
métropoles au risque d'écraser des
territoires périurbains et ruraux
car si les métropoles font rêver encore
faux tels que les métropoles n'écrase
pas je vais prendre un exemple picard
entre la métropole lilloise
la métropole de paris quid d'amiens et
de la picardie et de ces territoires qui
seront littéralement mes chers collègues
écrasé entre deux métropoles un peu
rejetés comme l'est la très grande
couronne parisienne par rapport à paris
métropole vous qui dénonce y est il y à
18 mois le gel des ressources des
collectivités territoriales vous voilà
acceptant des coups de rabot en amputant
les collectivités territoriales de
quatre milliards et demi de ressources
certes nous devons tous faire des
efforts de maîtrise des dépenses
publiques
mais là on peut dire que vous y allez
fort vous qui dénonce y ait la création
du conseiller territorial
il devait créer de la synergie entre
régions et départements
vous proposez en fait de faire du
département une coquille vide et de la
plupart de ses compétences
simple exécutant guichet social d'une
politique décidée au plan national le
département soit pierre raffarin le
rappeler le premier partenaire de la
rivalité est un acteur de cohésion
sociale majeure et les bond de le
rappeler dans ce pays
c'est un acteur majeur de notre cohésion
mais inquiétant aussi à mes yeux est que
vous vous attaquez un présent des sens
même de nos territoires
je ne reviendrai pas pour lui rebat que
je suis là tu as contre la ruralité ne
cesse de se répéter
semaine après semaine or la ruralité ça
n'est pas qu'une nostalgie des
territoires faiblement peuplé c'est
aussi je le rappelle un espace assez
exceptionnel pour la richesse économique
de notre pays
le rappelait que l'agriculture et la
filière agroalimentaire
c'est le deuxième poste de l' équilibre
dans le déséquilibre de notre balance du
commerce extérieur
mais au fond nous ne sommes pas les
seuls au groupe ump sans doute c'est nos
amis du groupe centriste udi à être
inquiet c'est vous même mes chers
collègues du groupe socialiste qui avait
livré ces derniers jours vos états d'âme
et vos inquiétudes dans les médias sur
les menaces que le gouvernement fait
courir aux collectivités territoriales à
tel point que le gouvernement n'a pu
s'obstiner à vouloir passer son texte
très longs en force
c'est le président du groupe socialiste
monsieur rebsamen qui le disait la
semaine dernière dans un média je le
cite je ferai part premier ministe de la
réticence formulées par un certain
nombre de sénateurs socialistes
une grande partie des sénateurs
socialistes la quasi totalité
je le cite c'est le président du sénat
qui a écrit au président de la
république pour lui demander de
repousser à l'automne
l'examen de ce texte il suffit d'avoir
eu entre les mains votre madame le
ministre ps le vôtre votre avant projet
de loi pour comprendre
pour comprendre il n'a de
décentralisation que le titre toutes les
associations d'élus et je relisais le
président le breton il y à peu quelle
que soit la strate collectivité qu'il
représente me paraissent assez unanimes
votre texte ne va rien simplifié et pour
reprendre l'exemple de la métropole de
paris y rajoute même une couche à
d'autres couches alors je me félicite
que notre détermination à porter les
inquiétudes des élus locaux et
contribuer à faire reculer le
gouvernement
car les premiers à avoir dit non ce sont
les sénateurs de l'opposition
et ce particulièrement du groupe ump en
annonçant hier matin que la réforme
serait divisé en plusieurs projets de
loi et que leurs examens seraient
retardées le premier ministre a avoué
implicitement que ce texte si l'on si
lourd si techno si déséquilibrée entre
nos collectivités territoriales était
bâclé et d'autre part une nouvelle fois
il n'y avait pas de majorité ici
pour le voter mais nous aurons d'autres
rencontres où il y aura sans doute
d'autres majorités qui sur d'autres
sujets qui touchent nos collectivités
territoriales nous ouvrirons à des
débats qui nous permettront je l'espère
de nous rapprocher dans l'intérêt de
notre territoire et de nos collectivités
territoriales alors mes chers collègues
mes chers collègues si vous pensez vous
de la majorité sénatoriale que les
principes qui régissent les droits de
liberté les collectivités sont
aujourd'hui menacés je crois qu'il faut
partager avec nous ce texte de
résolution qui rappelle les principes
constitutionnels qui s'impose à
l'exécutif
c'est notre rôle à nous sénateurs c'est
la mission de l'article 24 que la
constitution nous a confié alors si vous
voulez supprimer de fait la commune sa
clause de compétence générale
vous trouverez sur le sénat vous
retrouverez le sénat sur votre route
si vous voulez supprimer de fait la
commune entre et voyant partir de 2020
l'élection au suffrage universel direct
des intercommunalités comme le président
de la république l'affirmé aux maires
des grandes villes
alors je pense que le sénat sera sur
votre route si vous voulez remettre en
cause la libre administration des
collectivités en faisant du département
cette collectivité croupion vous
trouverez le sénat sur votre route
alors mes chers collègues il y a la
responsabilité d'assumer notre rôle
constitutionnel
voilà pourquoi cette mission commune
comme nous en avions créé une il y a
maintenant près de trois ans et demi
elle m'apparaît indispensable pour la
diversité dans la diversité de nos
sensibilités
essayez d'imaginer ensemble en dépassant
le clivage le territoire qui demain
contribuera à sortir de notre pays de
cette j'allais dire crise de longueur
profonde qui est en train de le conduire
à la désespérance nos collectivités
territoriales ou un rôle essentiel
dans la suite du débat la parole est à
monsieur jean pierre sueur du groupe
socialiste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues j'ai lu nous avons
lu avec beaucoup de soin votre
proposition de résolution et je dois
vous dire d'emblée que je ne vois pas
pour quelle raison nous nous opposerions
à cette résolution mes chers collègues
je vous remercie
je ne sais pas si les applaudissements
vont durer je l'espère car enfin j'ai
acquis depuis quelques temps un
exemplaire de la constitution est jolie
je m'en imprègne pour que cette loi
fondamentale guide chaque jour nos
actions nos réflexions et tout
simplement notre travail de législateur
donc mes chers collègues dans cependant
cette proposition de résolution
vous reprenez 6 ou 7 alinéa de la
constitution mais oui mais alors la
question qui se pose d'abord vous en
conviendrez est de savoir quelle est
l'utilité de faire une résolution pour
recopier la constitution vous voyez bien
qu'il est très difficile de voter contre
et que la seule question qui se pose est
de savoir à quoi ça sert bon ça sert à
parler mais nous sommes un parlement
donc user de cela dans mes chers
collègues
ce sera votée par notre groupe parce que
je je n'imagine pas que nous puissions
ne pas voter la constitution de la
république française
vous nous avez présenté monsieur
raffarin avec beaucoup de lyrisme
monsieur larcher avec vigueur eu une
vision de l'histoire
on pourrait peut-être mettre quelques
nuances
moi j'étais un jeune député en 1981 2 81
82 depuis naturellement comme je dis
souvent dans mon département je suis
devenu un jeune sénateur mais
entre-temps j'ai relu figurez vous un
jour les débats sur la loi de 80,2 je
vous conseille par exemple mais vraiment
fait le de lire les propos de monsieur
pierre méhaignerie et d'autres que je ne
citerai pas qu'ils se dresser contre
cette atteinte à l'état républicain à
l'unité de la république
et alors il n'avait pas de mots assez
forts pour s'opposer à ce texte
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde salue et
vous avez bien raison de saluer françois
mitterrand gaston defferre et pierre
mauroy et puis il y a eu ses loire de 92
d'abord est de 99 ensuite qui ont créé
les communautés de communes d'abord il a
fallu plus de temps pour les communautés
d'agglomération c'est vrai et combien de
fois n'avons nous pas dit les
communautés ne sont pas contre les
communes nous avons 36700 commune nous
les aimons tous nous les avons dans le
coeur comme les français ces communes
mais nous savons bien que si on fait des
communautés aujourd'hui et si vous avez
d'ailleurs proposer une loi pour
généraliser les communautés à toute la
france c'est parce que l'on sert les
communes en dix ans gardons cet échelon
de proximité qui est tellement important
pour nous mais coopérons on ne va pas
dans chaque commune une zone d'activités
mutualisons les efforts pour que cela
soit efficace et tout le monde comprend
cela et puis je me souviens de la loi
présenté par jean-pierre raffarin
puisque nous étions à cette époque-là au
sénat dans l'opposition en effet mais
vous savez cela va et vient eh bien je
me souviens d'une déclaration de jean
pierre raffarin qui m'avait frappé quand
cette loi a été présenté vous avez dit
l'avenir c'est les régions et je vais
vous présenter une loi qui va donner
toute sa force toute sa place toute sa
vigueur dans l'espace européen
au fait régional je dois vous dire chers
premier ministre qu après quelques
débats ici et là votre loi régionaliste
et peu un peu devenu la plus grande loi
départementaliste qu'on ait jamais fait
et je crois que vous n'en étiez pas
c'est un peu rapide mais ce n'est pas
totalement faux
vous en conviendrez est alors
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je vois monsieur le premier
ministre jean pierre raffarin que vous
nous faites l'éloge des départements je
remarque une chose c'est que dans votre
résolution
vous ne parlez pas des départements le
mot n'est pas prononcé
il n'y a pas écrit mais peut-être
pourriez-vous ajouté un alinéa ni
d'ailleurs des régions
d'ailleurs vous ne parlez pas non plus
des élus vous ne parlez pas non plus de
l'état parce que vous savez mais vous
parlez des principes et vous avez tout à
fait raison puisque nous vous approuve
haut et puisque nous allons voter votre
texte de marquer votre attachement à la
constitution de la république française
il ya eu les états généraux et vous avez
bien voulu rappeler que les états
généraux organisés par jean pierre bel
président du sénat ont donné lieu à une
grande concertation dans toute la france
dans les départements et ici même
simplement je me souviens j'ai je me
permets de rappeler quand même
cela s'est très bien passé à une
exception petit prêt c'est que alors que
nous étions tous là dans les ateliers
dans cet hémicycle dans la salle des
conférences
voilà que sur le coup de 16 heures
monsieur jean claude gaudin invite les
journalistes à venir dans son bureau
pour dire mais non tout cela c'est une
figuration ce n'est pas ce qu'il faut et
alors ce qui a été bien quand même c'est
que la très grande majorité des élus
locaux venus au sénat qu'ils fussent de
droite de gauche ou du centre sont
revenus le lendemain à la sorbonne et
ont participé à ces états généraux qui
ont d'ailleurs permis d'écrire deux
propositions de lois qui ont été votées
par le sénat et qui je l'espère seront
bientôt votée à l'assemblée nationale
c'est vrai qu'il y à des débats sur la
décentralisation vous l'avez dit
monsieur larcher et comme monsieur
raffarin et c'est tout à fait vrai que
nous sommes un certain nombre dans le
groupe socialiste avoir dit au
gouvernement qu'il était nécessaire de
revoir
l'avant projet de loi qui avait été
préparé madame la ministre
mais enfin nous sommes dans un pays où
nous aimons parler vrai y compris au
gouvernement que nous soutenons et je
peux vous dire parce que j'y ai
participé qu'il y a eu un certain nombre
de dialogues qu'il ya un certain nombre
de propositions et que je trouve que ce
qui a été annoncé hier par le premier
ministre est intéressant car nous ne
pouvons pas ici nous sommes entre nous
mais même si nous n'étions pas entre
nous opposer les différents niveaux
il est proposé trois projets de loi il
faudra que ces projets de loi soit
peaufiner eux donnent lieu au débat
parlementaire le plus approfondi
je commencerai par le troisième les
solidarités territoriales et c'est
pourquoi j'en parle en premier les
solides la dame kerman les solidarités
territoriales
mais il n'est pas renvoyé moi je propose
monsieur larcher je le dis ici on a le
droit en tant que parlementaires de
faire des propositions
je propose que ces trois projets madame
la ministre fait une proposition
gouvernement soit présenté en même temps
et que l'on discute des solidarités
territoriales en insistant sur le rôle
irremplaçable des départements dans la
solidarité
nous savons qu'ils qu'aujourd'hui dans
notre pays le département joue un rôle
essentiel
je ne vois aucune possibilité pour la
région pour les intercommunalités de se
substituer aujourd'hui au rôle du
département les communes aussi bien sûr
second volet des régions fortes non pas
contre les départements contre les
communes ou les communautés mais avec
elle des régions fortes en particulier
pour l'économie et pour l'emploi
parce que ce sont les premières
préoccupations de nos concitoyens et que
nous savons que dans l'europe que nous
connaissons dans le monde que nous
connaissons des régions fortes sont
absolument nécessaires
vous avez dit je crois que c'est
monsieur jean pierre raffarin qui a dit
que dans sa région
le budget de la région étaient
inférieures au budget de tous les
départements qui composent la région
et bien moi je dis que ce n'est pas
normal et je suis partisan de région qui
est plus de force plus de moyens plus de
compétences mais j'ai commencé par dire
le rôle irremplaçable der département
pour la solidarité ne soyons pas dans
l'opposition mais dans la
complémentarité et les métropoles et
bien les métropoles et les grandes
agglomérations doivent aussi avoir toute
la force nécessaire pour le futur mais
moi je dis qu'il nous faut des régions
fortes
des départements solidaire et des
communautés vivantes active
entreprenante et quand je dis communauté
je parle de la plus grande métropole ou
de la deuxième et de la troisième et
nous pensons à paris à lyon à marseille
a d'autres comme de la plus petite
communauté de communes dont l'objectif
est de créer un vrai dynamisme pour le
développement économique au sein du
monde rural
donc je ne crois pas qu'il y ait
d'opposition bien alors pour finir bien
sûr on m'a dit bon je vais aussi penser
dans le fond nos collègues de l'ump il
nous présente un catalogue de beaux
principes mais bien sûr j'ai dit que
c'était la constitution ses bras nous
allons le goûter mais l'on t-il toujours
appliqué bas vous savez j'ai lu
corneille oui monsieur le premier musée
lui corneille vous savez dans le cid
les exemples vivants sont vingt autres
pouvoirs alors quand vous nous parler de
la nécessaire autonomie financière des
collectivités
vous me permettrez quand même
amicalement de vous faire observer que
la magnifique
enfin jeudi magnifique par antiphrase
réforme de la taxe groupe professionnel
que vous avez mis en place les chers
collègues s'est traduite
oui oui oui monsieur lenoir s'est
traduite pour ce qui est des marges de
manoeuvre de l'autonomie fiscale des
collectivités
soyons mais monsieur d'allier soyons
soyons très clairs la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle s'est traduit pour ce
qui est de l'autonomie fiscale des
collectivités par un passage pour le
bloc communal communes et communautés de
48% à 41 % pour les départements de 35 %
à 16 % d'autonomie fiscale est alors
pour les régions de 30 % à 14 %
d'autonomie fiscale et l an moyennant
quoi vous nous dites point numéro aligne
à neuf le sénat
d'après la proposition de résolution du
groupe ump rappelle que l'autonomie
financière des collectivités
territoriales est une garantie
constitutionnelle b c'est vrai
simplement ce n'est pas mauvais non plus
de mettre en oeuvre ce que l'on dit
quand on est au pouvoir et d'ailleurs
j'ai retrouvé un excellent rapport du
sénat par rapport à ce blocage de la
situation pour les régions parler aux
élus régionaux qu'ils soient de la
majorité de l'opposition
ils vont vous dire que seule la fixation
des tarifs de carte grise ainsi que
d'une faible part de la tei pp pouvant
être déterminée par les régions et bien
la situation est complètement paralysée
et j'ai retrouvé un excellent apport du
sénat cet excellent rapport je le cite
il dit que je les cite est ce soir à
dessein bah oui vous voyez bien monsieur
le président je cite entre guillemets
les régions françaises sont la catégorie
de collectivités territoriales
qui a le plus souffert de la réforme de
la taxe professionnelle en termes
d'autonomie fiscale et voient donc leur
marge de manoeuvre particulièrement
réduite
c'est signé par qui par monsieur charles
guené monsieur le président je vous
salue pour votre lucidité et madame anne
marie escoffier qui était alors
sénatrice qui est depuis une brillante
ministre de la décentralisation et qui
ont fait qu'ils ont fait un constat
parfaitement lucide
alors mes chers collègues gardons un peu
d'humour voyons qu'il est très bien de
proclamer les principes eux
faisons en sorte de les respecter
nous allons tous nous y employer du
mieux que nous pourrons j'ai encore
d'autres citations celle de monsieur
bruno le maire qui vous savez été
délégués je crois à l'époque de l'ump
qui a dit qu'il fallait réduire de deux
milliards par an les concours de l'état
aux collectivités locales
et même il nous a dit que ce n'était
qu'une base minimale qu'il fallait aller
plus loin on pourrait sortir beaucoup
d'autres choses mais disons que ce débat
entre nous et qui est intéressant nous
permettra à chacun de progresser vers la
bonne application de la constitution de
la république française qui est notre
constitution commune que vous recopiez à
juste titre et à laquelle nous
programmerons une fois encore notre
attachement en bon républicain que nous
sommes je vous remercie
dans la suite du débat la parole est à
monsieur christian favier du groupe crc
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous noterons pour
commencer que les auteurs de cette
proposition de résolution n'ont pas
hésité à reprendre le titre même de la
loi defferre de 1982 alors qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui on le sait les représentants
de ceux qui à l'époque l'avaient
combattu avec beaucoup de véhémence dans
le même esprit je veux souligner d'abord
tout le paradoxe du contenu de cette
résolution
venant d'un groupe parlementaire qui on
le sait durant dix ans a mis à mal les
collectivités territoriales bafouant ont
de multiples occasions les principes
constitutionnels qu'il semble
aujourd'hui vouloir défendre
en effet tout de même comment oublier
que l'ump qui prétend aujourd'hui
vouloir défendre la libre administration
des communes est à l'origine d'un
transfert massif de compétences de
l'état vers les collectivités sans les
compensations financières nécessaires et
pérenne prenant le risque on sait de les
étouffer
vous le savez bien il y a plusieurs
milliards mon cher collègue plusieurs
milliards d'euros aujourd'hui duo
département au titre des allocations de
solidarité nationale l'a pas la pch le
et le rsa qui n'ont jamais été
effectivement compenser pour les
collectivités départementales et qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui des départements
sont de votre responsabilité au bord de
la faillite
comment oublier que la majorité d'hier a
supprimé l'autonomie fiscale et la
compétence générale des départements et
des régions à supprimer la loi de 2010 a
supprimé la taxe professionnelle et
instauré le conseiller territorial en
lieu et place des conseillers généraux
et régionaux
comment oublier que la loi de 2010 qui a
contraint les communes ou regroupements
forcés au sein de nouvelles
intercommunalités au périmètre aux
compétences élargies
afin de parvenir comme le préconisait la
commission balladur à l'évaporation des
communes pourront pas dire à leur
disparition
comment oublier enfin la destruction du
tissu local que les sénateurs de ce
groupe ont soutenu la rgpp qui a mis à
mal de nombreux services publics locaux
avec en particulier ces milliers de
fermetures de classes et d'écoles de
bureaux de poste de tribunaux sans
compter compris les nombreux champs
d'amauri comment justifier donc
aujourd'hui un tel décalage entre la
prise de position d'aujourd'hui et votre
action parlementaire d'hier vous avez
fait durant dix ans l'exact contraire de
ce que vous prenez aujourd'hui dans
cette résolution
aussi s'il s'agit donc que d'une petite
opération politique pour tenter sans
doute de faire oublier autres actions
passées et vos réelles convictions elle
ne grandit pas ses auteurs et le fait
que renforcer il faut bien le dire la
rhétorique de tous ceux qui mettent
aujourd'hui en cause l'honnêteté
intellectuelle des politiques s'il
s'agit pour vous de l'expression d'un
droit d'inventaire pourquoi pas
contestant le bien fondé de tout ce que
vous avez fait alors nous vous proposons
un acte bien plus fort en demandant donc
avec nous l'abrogation de la loi de
décembre 2010 car pour notre part ce
principe de la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales
nous y sommes attachés comme la prunelle
de nos yeux
nous en avons apporté la preuve je crois
d'abord à chaque fois qu'a pouvoir
central s'y attaquer tout autre
argumentaire comme votre réforme de 2010
était fondé sur la défense de la libre
administration de nos collectivités pour
leur libre coopération contre toutes les
formes d'intégration autoritaire et sur
vauban évidemment lorsque nous
défendions ces principes nous étions
alors accusé d'archaïsme car nous les
défendrons pied à pied plus près de nous
il ya quelques jours nous avons refusé
le fléchage des conseillers
communautaires qui entérine le fait que
les communes qui devront délégué leurs
compétences garou en même temps leur
pouvoir de contrôle sur leur mise en
oeuvre
puisque les conseillers communautaires
ne représenteront plus les conseils
municipaux et n'auront donc plus de
comptes à leur ombre enfin notre
inquiétude
vous le savez reste forte madame la
ministre devant les textes de loi
annoncé concernant donc la future loi de
décentralisation aussi passer notre
étonnement devant tant de soudain
sollicitude de la part de nos collègues
de l'ump envers les collectivités
territoriales et nos communes en
particulier venant de ceux qui les ont
combattues
nous aurions pu évidemment nous
contenter de dénoncer une certaine forme
d'hypocrisie des auteurs de cette
résolution est refusé de prendre part au
vote d'une telle déclaration d'intention
à laquelle nous souscrivons par ailleurs
pour l'essentiel mais qui est à cent
lieues et d'amendés actes de ceux qui la
propose mais finalement persuadé que ce
texte exprime une certaine façon avant
tout le mécontentement grandissant
devant la situation que les locaux
subissent nous avons ouï décidé de le
soutenir pour marquer une nouvelle fois
notre profond attachement à ces valeurs
républicaines nous voulons ainsi
permettre au sénat d'affirmer ses
principes
où qu'il soit effectivement aujourd'hui
entendues à la veille des futures lois
de décentralisation qui à notre sens
mettent à mal la libre administration
l'autonomie financière et fiscale la non
tu telle est la libre coopération de
toutes les collectivités territoriales à
ce propos nous serons particulièrement
vigilants pour s'assurer par exemple que
les plans locaux d'urbanisme resteront
de compétence communale transférables de
façon facultative aux intercommunalités
et ce quel que soit le texte de loi qui
fera référence
aussi malgré les lacunes du projet de
résolution qui nous est présenté en
particulier n'ait rien dit effectivement
sur la compensation intégrale et qui ne
dit pas la nécessaire prise en compte de
l'évolution des dépenses des compétences
transférées et qui surtout lui la
nécessité de maintenir la clause de
compétence générale aux départements aux
régions qui sont effectivement pas cités
dans cette résolution
oui malgré ses lacunes nous la
soutiendrons nous soutiendrons sa texte
ce vote ne sera pas évidemment chacun
l'a bien compris
un blanc seing à l'ump pour son action
écoulée ni pour ses combats futurs sa
vision votre vision libérale de
l'organisation territoriale aux frais
public je crois la disqualifie à nos
yeux
par ce vote nous souhaitons réaffirmer
notre engagement aux côtés des élus
locaux et nos concitoyens pour assurer
le développement de notre démocratie
locale entrer dans des communes des
départements et des régions respectés
dans leurs droits et libertés associons
toujours plus les citoyens alors action
au service de tous et pour répondre à
leurs besoins et à leurs attentes
en votant ce texte de résolution donc
nous engageons pour l'avenir en
réaffirmant la nécessité de respecter
ces principes nous nous engageons à agir
pour les faire respecter dans les
futures lois dans toutes les lois qu'une
seront soumises qu'elle concerne
l'urbanisme l'action sociale le
développement économique ou les finances
et nous verrons bien alors qui respecte
ses engagements et nous serons alors
aussi rappelé leur vote à tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui adopteront ce texte
dans la suite du débat la parole est
maintenant monsieur jean léonce dupont
du groupe u10 uc
le président
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le 3 juillet dernier
lecture était faite au sénat de la
déclaration de politique générale du
gouvernement
à cette occasion nous avons pu entendre
je cite il est fini le temps où l'état
imposer ses décisions des collectivités
territoriales qu'il considérait comme de
simples satellite chargé d'exécuter sa
volonté
nous ouvrons la porte à une évolution
profonde un bouleversement inédit
je demande à chacun d'en prendre la
mesure et d'ajouter je crois à la
nécessité d'un état stratège garant de
la cohérence des politiques publiques et
de la solidarité entre les citoyens et
les territoires j'ai alors pris bonne
note de cet engagement solennel puis
lors de la séance de clôture des états
généraux de la démocratie territoriale
le président de la république nous
annonçait vouloir un acte iii de la
décentralisation sans aucune
simplification administrative
mais avec près de 1,5 milliard d'euros
de ressources en moins au mois de
janvier nous avons appris que la facture
serait sans doute davantage de l'ordre
de 5 milliards d'euros avec en prime le
transfert de compétences nouvelles 100
simplifications préalable des normes
alors mes chers collègues malgré ses
efforts de communication et dénonce la
politique gouvernementale me désappointé
car le malaise est grand c'est pourquoi
la présentation de la proposition de
résolution de jean claude gaudin et de
ses collègues n'intervient pas à un
moment anodin
certes le mois de mars est celui d'un
double anniversaire celui du premier et
du deuxième acte de la décentralisation
alors que nous avons célébré l'an
dernier le 30e anniversaire de la loi de
faire du 2 mars 82 et que nous célébrons
ce mois ci le dixième anniversaire de la
révision constitutionnelle de mars 2003
cher au premier ministre jean pierre
raffarin on peut mesurer le chemin
parcouru telle qu'enseignée dans les
facultés de droit la décentralisation
semble limpide la loi de 82 à jeter les
fondements
politiques administratives notre
nouvelle organisation administrative
quand le cycle législatives de 2003
introduisez le principe de l'autonomie
financière et consacré
constitutionnellement la forme
décentralisée de la république
la distance est pourtant grande entre ce
qui est enseigné est ce que nous vivons
sur le terrain de la théorie à la
pratique il n'ya pas un pas il ya
désormais un fossé pourquoi rappeler
aujourd'hui les grands principes
constitutionnels et l'organisation nos
territoires le constat est partagé en
sous-vêtements à l'excès des compétences
des collectivités
non trop important et morcellement des
structures d'administration territoriale
nécessaire réforme des finances locales
dans un contexte marqué par une
augmentation conséquente des dépenses
des collectivités locales et d'une
stagnation quand ce n'est pas une
diminution des recettes outre
l'organisation administrative de
territoires trop complexe les
collectivités leurs élus souffre d'
asphyxie normative et d' asphyxie
financière la 6e' normative est un sujet
d'actualité
tous les médias en ont parlé ces
derniers jours avec la remise du rapport
de monsieur lambert et boulard qui
pointent quelques normes irrationnel
mais cette énième rapport recommande de
supprimer 23 normes sur les 400 milles
normes qui pèsent sur les collectivités
locales les gouvernements successifs ont
pas non c'est parfois présenté des
textes de simplification administrative
et d'allègement des normes des
parlementaires ont présenté également
des textes en ce sens les dernières
initiatives de monsieur warsmann à
l'assemblée nationale de monsieur doligé
au sénat ont pourtant connu de vrais
parcours du combattant pour être discuté
au point de se demander si la volonté de
simplification du gouvernement est bien
réelle mercredi dernier le président de
la république a promis un choc de
simplifications administratives pour les
entreprises
très bien attendons la concrétisation de
cette promesse supplémentaires mais en
même temps j'appelle de mes voeux un
solde de simplification normative pour
les collectivités en tant qu'élus nous
dénonçons tous l'excès de normes et des
conséquences charges financières
insupportables pour les collectivités
situation de blocage ou d'absurdité
inégalités entre les citoyens du fait de
l'application ou de la non application
des normes inégalités entre les
territoires frein au développement
économique
malheureusement les rapports se
succèdent dresse des constats puis
aucune suite ou presque rien pour ma
part je les ai dit je trouve
intéressante l'idée d'un principe de
proportionnalité des normes et de leur
possible adaptation à la situation
financière des collectivités et aux
réalités locales
la loi handicap de février 2005 est un
bon exemple de bonnes intentions qui sur
le terrain pose de difficultés
techniques et financières considérables
notamment aux petites communes nous
avons la chance d'être un pays d'un
riche patrimoine
l'accessibilité de tous les lieux
publics aux personnes handicapées pour
2015 est un bel objectif mais un vrai
casse tête pour bon nombre d'élus il ne
s'agit pas ici de plaider pour un retour
en arrière ou un non respect de la loi
mais m un peu de souplesse me paraît
indispensable si on veut pas enrayer
l'action locale déjà très contrainte
concernant la succise financière nos
concitoyens n'ont pas vraiment
conscience et pourtant c'est le plus
grand danger qui menace les
collectivités territoriales dans le
rapport d'information monsieur hervé
intitulé trente ans de décentralisation
contribution à un bilan cette question
cruciale est posée que valent les
principes constitutionnels relatifs à la
décentralisation proclamé l'autonomie
des collectivités c'est très bien mais
sans leur donner d'autonomie fiscale
ça devient un leurre une illusion
constitutionnel avec la demande avec la
diminution de l'autonomie fiscale
accentuée par la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle
le principe de libre administration des
collectivités territoriales se trouve
réduit or l'autonomie locale se mesure
aux moyens dont dispose la collectivité
à champ de compétence à l'indépendance
de ces décideurs à leurs prérogatives en
matière d'intervention à la nature du
lien avec l'état l'autonomie fiscale ça
a été dit régional est aujourd'hui
autour de 10% celle du département de 16
% celle de l'ensemble des communes et
pci 40%
ces chiffres illustrent la marge de
manoeuvre de plus en plus ténue
des collectivités certains départements
n'ont ils pas craint la cessation de
paiement du fait de la compensation très
insuffisante des dépenses sociales
obligatoires qui plombent les budgets
des départements surtout les plus ruraux
alors que l'état se désengage chaque
jour un peu plus de l'investissement
public et de l'exercice de nombreuses
compétences
il garde la main sur des ressources qui
devraient normalement venir financer les
nouvelles missions des territoires
ce constat est un peu caricatural je
vous la corde l'état transfère des
ressources fiscales mais des ressources
archaïque peu dynamique en décalage avec
la réalité du besoin de financement des
politiques publiques locales
dans ce contexte je ne peux que soutenir
la proposition de résolution de monsieur
gaudin elle n'est qu'un rappel opportun
en forme de signal d'alarmé au moment où
est annoncé un acte iii de la
décentralisation dont les avant projets
sont déjà particulièrement décriée de
temps en temps au sein même de tous les
groupes
certains l'ont qualifié de texte
fourre-tout anachronique monstrueux
plaçant les collectivités en situation
de servitude avant l'examen au sénat de
ce projet de loi que nous examinerons
vous l'imaginez avec une extrême
vigilance
il reste quelques jours elle je sais
madame la ministre que vous y êtes
attentive au gouvernement pour affiner
sa copie ou devrais je dire
ces copies et présenter des textes
orientation claire respectueux de la
libre administration des collectivités
locales
alpha 1 qu'elle demeure le premier
investisseur public en france avec des
budgets équilibrés et une dette publique
locale plus de dix fois inférieur à la
dette de l'état et afin que n'existent
pas demain la tutelle d'une collectivité
sur une autre collectivité fût-ce par
l'artifice de la présence de l'état
dans la suite du débat la parole est à
monsieur jacques mézard
le groupe rdse monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
tout d'abord je voudrais saluer madame
la ministre
le sérieux de son travail son courage
dans une mission difficile et lui dire
le regret personnel qu'elle n'ait pas eu
vraiment en charge directement la
préparation de l'acte iii de la
décentralisation
mes chers collègues de l'ump nous
voterons cette résolution nous la
voterons et on nettoie vous permettez
moi de vous dire que je pense qu'elle se
dissoudra dans une joyeuse unanimité
mais ceci étant ceci étant le constat
que vous avez fait en reprenant la
constitution que nous respectons tous
permettez moi oui mais ça fait un peu
cheap permettez moi mon cher collègue
compte tenu de l'évolution de ces
derniers jours ceci étant je crois que
ce débat a un intérêt à un intérêt parce
que ils rappellent très simplement et je
le dis autant à mes collègues de l'ump
que du parti socialiste que vous avez
manifestement l'art de vouloir faire
quand vous êtes dans l'opposition ce que
vous n'avez pas fait quand vous étiez
dans la majorité et réciproquement
mais c'est une constatation habituel
permettez-moi aussi permettez aux
jacobins que je suis il en reste encore
de ne pas partager l'euphorie de
monsieur le premier ministre raffarin
r c'est chez les girondins je craint
particulièrement les nouveaux convertis
je me souviens je me souviens en
particulier des propos que nous avons
tendu moi j'ai fait partie comme
d'autres de la mission bello sur
l'évaporation des départements qui les
auraient oublié aujourd'hui argentan des
dommages et des autres départements et
si je puis me permettre je trouve que ce
qui manque dans ses réformes successives
dont nous avons tous le sentiment
qu'elles sont absolument indispensables
cette une prospective politique une
vision politique et du courage politique
car les uns et les autres à chaque à
chaque étape on se rend compte que les
blocages sont immenses
et quand on commence par quoi par
consulter toutes les strates tous les
représentants de toutes les associations
à chaque niveau qu'ils disent
naturellement les uns et les autres
après les autres que chez eux tout va
bien que ce serait encore un peu mieux
s'il en avait un peu plus et évidemment
les étapes successives des
décentralisations ont amené des progrès
mais aussi malheureusement beaucoup de
complexité
une absence de clarification et la vraie
difficulté
elle est là aujourd'hui vous nous avez
rappelé sur le président larcher
l'excellent travail de la mission belot
nous y avons participé c'était je crois
un bel effort de l'ensemble du sénat et
de toutes ses composantes
nous étions arrivés je crois un assez
large consensus
et malheureusement ce consensus il a été
détruit
il a été détruit parce que le
gouvernement a cru opportun nous
pensions c'était inopportun de prendre
des dispositions qui ne correspondaient
pas au consensus qui ressortait de la
mission l'eau nous avons eu récemment
des états généraux de la démocratie
territoriale beaucoup de choses utiles
ont été dites et il n'y a eu dans nos
départements et avec toutes les
sensibilités
une véritable consultation et nous avons
les uns et des autres en tant que vu ce
que nous disaient nos collègues élus des
collectivités locales je regrette que le
gouvernement aujourd'hui n'en est pas à
totalement tirer les conclusions
pourquoi parce que les mêmes difficultés
les mêmes blocages sont au rendez-vous
et que tant qu'il n'y aura pas la
définition d'une politique et que cette
politique ne sera pas présentée par le
gouvernement en disant c'est ma
politique vous la voulez où vous ne la
voulez pas et en compte
consultera à longueur d'année les uns et
les autres qui répondront
systématiquement les mêmes choses il
sera difficile de simplifier il sera
difficile de clarifier les relations
entre les collectivités les relations
entre les collectivités et l'état
et nous ne vivons aussi parce que quand
je dis que il me reste largement un
esprit jacobin
ce que je constate c'est que la vème
république à abandonner purement et
simplement une véritable politique
d'aménagement du territoire et nous le
vivons tous les jours et de plus en plus
quels que soient les gouvernements
qu'ils soient de droite ou de gauche
alors chers collègues auteurs de cette
excellente résolution que nous allons
voter sans aucun état d'âme parce que
non seulement par attachement à la
constitution mais parce que ce que vous
dites nous le partageons et d'ailleurs
si je crois je le sentiment que presque
la totalité de l'assemblée va le voter
il faudrait que nous demandions si ce
consensus autour de cette constitution
nous ne pourrions pas le mettre à profit
pour essayer de construire ensemble
quelque chose d'utile avec une vraie
volonté politique
ça ne fera pas forcément plaisir à tout
le monde partout mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce que le pays
attend de nous alors vous nous dites
vous nous rappeler des éléments
importants mais jean pierre sueur avait
raison de dire que quand vous rappeler
que l'autonomie financière des
collectivités territoriales est une
garantie constitutionnelle de bénéficier
de ressources propres après ce qui s'est
passé avec la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle
je crois que quand même je vous n'avez
vraiment pas donner l'exemple
lorsque vous nous dites qu'il faut
affirmer la nécessité d'une compensation
intégrale des transferts de compétences
de l'état vers les collectivités
je dirais que tous les gouvernements de
sensibilités diverses ont fait la même
chose
malheureusement mais ils ont fait la
même chose
les
il est temps de revenir à de véritables
équilibre et quand vous concluez et vous
concluez wii va vous coûter vous auriez
pu le faire pendant dix ans et quand
vous concluez vous concluez en rappelant
la nécessité de développer une politique
volontariste en faveur de la ruralité et
d'assurer une répartition équitable des
moyens entre tous les territoires de la
république
permettez moi de vous dire en tant qu
élu d'un département très rural que dans
les dix dernières années
je n'ai jamais surtout dans les cinq
dernières années comme élu local et je
tiens vous le savez président larcher à
ce que les locales soient puissent aussi
être parlementaire
eh bien eh bien eh bien et j'en termine
là dessus sur le président larcher dans
ces cinq dernières années plutôt dans
ces six dernières années
jamais mon département n'a été autant
victimes dans l'histoire d'une telle
politique d'abandon de désertification
de retrait des services publics
et ça aussi il faut que vous l'entendiez
parce que c'est ce qu'il ne faut plus
faire ni les uns ni les autres
merci
dans la suite du débat la parole est à
monsieur joël labbé pour le groupe
écologie
sur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues cette journée du 3
avril 2013 est une eye et est une belle
journée marquée par le vote pour la
première fois dans l'histoire du
parlement d'une loi à l'initiative du
groupe écologiste la loi concernant l'
expertise en matière de santé
d'environnement
une loi qui est loin d'être anodine on
le verra dans le futur
par contre pour moi en mon for intérieur
comme j'en suis sûr pour beaucoup
d'entre vous cette journée est une
journée bien triste pour l'image de la
démocratie
je tenais à vous le dire entrée en bulle
au sujet de cette résolution je
n'insisterai pas sur l'exposé trop
sommaire que cette proposition de
résolution fait de l'histoire de la
décentralisation
je n'insisterai pas non plus sur le fait
que la décentralisation commence bien en
1982 et que la date de 2003 à laquelle
l'odeur eu l'auteur ou les auteurs de la
résolution
tiens t'en n'est que le dernier pas
d'une longue construction qui est encore
à venir
je constate aussi que vous êtes monsieur
raffarin et l'archet notamment avec
votre groupe attaché à cette
décentralisation
je veux y voir et je souhaite y voir une
preuve que vous allez collaborer de
manière constructive avec les groupes de
la majorité afin de dégager des
propositions fortes dont l'ensemble de
notre organisation territoriale a besoin
pour affronter les immenses défis qui
sont devant nous enfin je vois que cette
résolution aborde également les
conditions effectives de l'exercice de
la décentralisation à travers notamment
la garantie des transferts de ressources
afférentes aux compétences transmise et
l'exercice d'une certaine autonomie
fiscale
c'est d'ailleurs un soulagement de voir
que votre groupe se préoccupe de ne pas
dépouiller les collectivités qu'ils ont
pourtant contribué à mettre en
difficulté trop souvent en leur
transférant des ressources insuffisantes
au vu des charges des volumes notamment
en 2003 le respect strict de l'article
de la constitution est un est en effet
une condition sinequanone de la
décentralisation la position des
écologistes sur l'échelon communal est
quelque peu différente de la vôtre je
parle en connaissance de cause puisque
je suis maire d'une commune qui
s'appelle ça lol dans le morbihan depuis
1995 et parle donc avec le recul d'une
certaine expérience
s'il est en l'état actuel essentiel de
maintenir les petites les communes des
grandes aux plus petites
ce n'est pas pour leur permettre de
faire semblant de pouvoir s'occuper de
tous les sujets mais bien pour préserver
un échelon de proximité avec les
citoyennes et les citoyens de et de leur
permettre de tisser un lien avec leurs
élus locaux directs ne faisons pas
semblant
la grande majorité des communes ne
pourraient pas assurer l'ensemble de
leur clause de compétence générale
vous connaissez comme moi la situation
financière de beaucoup d'entre elles qui
leur permettent à peine pour les plus
petites d'assurer le coeur de leur
domaine d'intervention la commune en
l'état actuel de notre organisation de
teris territoriales devra rester à
l'avenir l'échelon privilégié de la
démocratie locale
l'organisation du débat public la
concertation avec les citoyens
la co construction des politiques
publiques avec les citoyennes et
citoyens ne peuvent être organisées que
dans la proximité
la commune doit devenir et rester
l'échelon privilégié de la démocratie
citoyenne garante des services publics
de grande proximité
je voudrais vous citez tocqueville pour
dire notre attachement à la commune
c'est dans la commune que réside la
force des peuples libres les
institutions communales sont à la
liberté ce que les écoles primaires sont
à la science elle les met à la portée du
peuple elle lui en font goûter lusage
paisible et l'habitude à s'en servir
ça mérite encore d'être réfléchi
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons pas nous
voiler la face en termes d'efficacité
deux gouttes de cohérence les problèmes
de transports d'infrastructures
d'assainissement de développement
économique ou encore de gestion des
déchets pour n'en citer que quelques-uns
ne peuvent être gérés au seul niveau des
communes elles n'en ont pas les moyens
tu es souvent elles n'en n'ont pas non
plus les compétences en termes de
services municipaux
nous sommes favorables à une
organisation de territoriale centré sur
deux échelons principaux et d'avenir
les intercommunalités et les régions ce
sont les seul échelon actuellement
capable de recouper les territoires
cohérents tout en disposant des
ressources financières suffisantes pour
relever les défis auxquels nos
territoires ont à faire face nous
n'obtiendrons rien de bon dans la
réforme territoriale à venir
si chacun cherche à préserver ses
intérêts particuliers à chaque échelon
de notre millefeuille territorial nos
régions ont montré au travers le
pluralisme de leurs compositions qu'elle
était capable de gérer des enjeux
complexes sur des territoires vastes en
étant clairement identifiés sur leur
domaine de compétence il faudra
également réfléchir à
l'approfondissement du pouvoir
d'adaptation réglementaire des régions
sur ce point l'analyse écologistes
pourra nourrir les débats je l'espère
notamment à travers le concept qui nous
est chère du fédéralisme différencié
avec en toile de fond avec en
perspective
l'idée de l'europe qui ne soit pas une
seule europe du marché mais une europe
politique sociale économique et
écologique
le parlement a fini par adopter un texte
garantissant la désignation directe par
les citoyens des élus siégeant au sein
des intercommunalités communalité mais
si ce texte ne correspond pas aux
attentes des écologistes notamment en
termes de pluralisme et de
représentation du territoire c'est un
premier pas et quand même un grand
premier pas nous devons aller plus loin
afin de faire émerger émerger des
projets de territoire correspondantes
aux spécificités des différents bassins
de vie
et d'activités quant au département nous
restons sceptiques sur leur maintien il
serait certainement certainement plus
efficace dans le futur de ventiler les
compétences de ceux ci sur les deux
échelons précédemment cités le rapport
de force nous est défavorable sur ce
point nous en convenons gageons que le
bon sens et l'intérêt général d'idron
nos décisions pour un avenir sur nos
territoires pour un avenir de nos
territoires équilibré et écologique
si nous partageons en grande partie les
termes de la résolution
notre groupe écologiste ne prendra pas
part au vote de ses rêves de sacre et
les une résolution qui selon nous mais
pas dénué d'arrière pensée conservatrice
qui ne nous conviennent pas je vous
remercie
dans la suite du débat la parole est est
à madame anne marie escoffier ministre
chargé de la décentralisation
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
me voici ce soir ce soir devant vous
ministre délégué auprès de la ministre
de la réforme de l'état de la
décentralisation et de la fonction
publique chargé de la décentralisation
un ministre heureux satisfait et plein
d'espérance heureux et satisfait d'avoir
entendu raconter la fantastique aventure
tel que vous l'avez raconté monsieur le
premier ministre raffarin de cette
décentralisation
vous qui avez parlé de l'anniversaire de
cette décentralisation heureux d'avoir
heureux d'avoir réentendu les grands
principes fondateurs qui régissent les
collectivités locales de notre
république principe constitutionnel
consacré par la constitution dans son
article 72 principe essentiel que celui
de la libre administration des
collectivités locales des l'autre des
collectivités locales qu'ils
s'administrent librement par des
conseillers élus principe mises en
oeuvre dès la première loi de
décentralisation du 2 mars 1982
vous l'avez rappelé je crois que c'est
une date importante parce que ce 2 mars
1982 était un vrai temps de rupture
un vrai temps de révolution par rapport
à un système antérieur à ce moment là
voilà qui était supprimé la tutelle
administrative et financière a priori
exercée par le préfet voilà l'exécutif
transféré du département ou de la région
à l'élu local les collectivités locales
bénéficient alors d'une véritable
personnalité juridique propre distincte
de l'état elles ont des droits
elles ont des obligations elle gère
librement les affaires qui
l'eev de leurs compétences elle possède
un patrimoine elle dispose d'agents
dotée du statut propre de la fonction
publique territoriale
elles gèrent elles gèrent de façon
autonome un budget la révision
constitutionnelle du 28 mars 2003 dont
vous avez souligné l'intervention oui
bien sûr elle est venue conforter tout
cela est ajouté un pouvoir réglementaire
pour l'exercice de leurs compétences et
donner la possibilité sous certaines
conditions de déroger à titre
expérimental aux dispositions
législatives ou réglementaires qui
régissent l'exercice de leurs
compétences
un point important messieurs que l'on a
peut-être pas assez dit ce soir et qui a
son importance
aujourd'hui dans l'autre vie de tous les
jours me voilà donc je le disais tout à
l'heure ministre satisfait de partager
avec vous surtout les brand ces
principes que vous avez décliné dans
votre résolution et qui tous relève du
principe de libre administration
principe d'autonomie financière de
l'article 72 de la constitution les
collectivités disposent dit le texte de
ressources suffisantes pour que le
nombre et le poids de leurs dépenses
obligatoires puisse être calculée à
l'aune de ses ressources
je sais je vous ai entendu vous avez dit
les uns et les autres les difficultés
financières que nous avons eu par le
passé et que nous voulons aujourd'hui
corrigée dans le cadre du pacte de
confiance et de responsabilité que nous
travaillons ensemble dans avec le comité
des finances locales et dans des groupes
de travail idoine pour essayer de
trouver des solutions à des difficultés
qui ont été recensés principe de la
compét' de la compensation des
transferts de compétences qui sont dit
dans l'article 72 de la constitution
je ne veux pas oublier le rôle
primordial
de la commission consultative
d'évaluation des charges qui doit être
le garant de ces compensations de
transfert principe de non tutelle d'une
collectivité locale sur un autre c'est
aussi un des principes auxquels nous
sommes tous attachés les principes de
libre administration
je ne soulignerai pas assez qu'il est le
principe fondamental la colonne
vertébrale
le véritable principe fondateur des
nouvelles entités qu'on était les
collectivités locales acteurs majeurs
aux côtés de l'état
vous l'avez dit les uns et les autres
acteurs ans qui l'état a placé sa
confiance une confiance qui est là pour
servir l'intérêt dans tous les cas du
citoyen votre résolution mesdames et
messieurs du sénateur choisi de
consacrer tout particulièrement la
commune cellule de base cellule à
l'image des cellules qui les unes avec
les autres
les unes à côté des autres formes et je
reprends l'image de la ruche la ruche
cellules toutes indépendantes les unes
des autres mais ensemble solidaire
je voudrais utiliser la belle formule la
belle devise de marguerite d'autriche et
philibert le beau fort une infortune
s'il n'y en a pas une c'est l'un fortune
qui resterait la commune lieu d'attache
des citoyens place irremplaçable des
élus ces communes qui ont un rôle clé
qui implique que soit confirmé comme l'a
fait le président la république
la clause générale de compétence
personne aujourd'hui ne conteste
l'organisation qui s'est mise en place
progressivement
l'intercommunalité je ne veux pas
remonter aux syndicats de communes qui
ont plus de son temps je ne remonterai
pas non plus là
ouah de 99 qui a été la loi fondamentale
qui a tjrs à imposer l'intercommunalité
qui a été reprise dans la loi du 10
décembre 2010 et qui aujourd'hui à
trouver sur l'ensemble du territoire
une organisation qui fait que à la date
de la fin de l'année 2012
il n'y avait que 59 communes isolées qui
restait sur l'ensemble du territoire
si l'on exclut les communes appartenant
à la petite couronne parisienne et les
communes qui appartenait aux îles mais
nominal 59 communes isolées
ça veut dire que l'ensemble du
territoire est aujourd'hui organisé
auprès des intercommunalités qui sont
bien le lieu qui tient compte de la
réalité des territoires qui rapproche
les communes sur la base de projets
partagés dans le cadre d'une véritable
communauté de destin d'une véritable
communauté de dessins et si on n'arrive
pas
justement à ce partage de projets assez
communauté de destin je crois qu'on
manque l'objectif de l'intercommunalité
l'intercommunalité qui veut être le vrai
lieu de proximité par rapport aux
citoyens apporter un meilleur service
aux citoyens mais en même temps
participer à la maîtrise des dépenses
voyez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je ne peux que me rendre aux
raisons de votre résolution stricte
observance de la constitution qui
prépare le terrain pour la réflexion que
nous conduirons ensemble que nous allons
mener dans le cadre de la réflexion sur
la réforme des collectivités
territoriales sur cet acte iii dont vous
avez parlé de la décentralisation
un texte que nous allons réfléchir
ensemble mais qui s'appuiera sur trois
principes fondateurs et auxquels je sais
que nous sommes tous ensemble attaché
principe d'unité de la république le
principe de la diversité des territoires
et mais aussi le principe de
subsidiarité trois principes fondateurs
qui doivent éclairer un texte qui
répondra aux objectifs de simplicité
d'efficacité et de maîtrise des dépenses
c'est le rendez vous que je vous donne
dans les jours prochains pour travailler
ensemble
une fois encore un texte qui répondra
aux attentes des citoyens et qui sera
écrit dans le strict respect de la
constitution
nous allons procéder au vote sur la
proposition de résolution et avant de
mettre aux voix la proposition de
résolution je dois vous informer que
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe ump pour la
applicables à la proposition de
résolution numéro 3 185 le respect des
droits et libertés des collectivités
territoriales je vous rappelle que le
vol la procédure nous allons procéder au
scrutin dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement ceux qui
souhaitent voter pour remettront
secrétaire un bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre
remettront un bulletin bleu ceux qui
souhaitent s'abonner remettront un
bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
comme ça
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à à voter donc
le scrutin est clos
j'invite mesdames et messieurs les
secrétaires a procédé au dépouillement
du scrutin
son
bon résultat du scrutin numéro 124 sur
la proposition de résolution relative au
respect des droits et libertés des
collectivités territoriales nombre de
votants 334 nombre de suffrages exprimés
334 pour l'adoption 334
le sénat a adopté voilà pour cette
séance si vous souhaitez la revoir elle
est disponible en vod sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous avec les travaux
parlementaires c'est cet après midi à
partir de 15 heures vous pourrez d'abord
suivre en direct la séance de questions
cribles thématiques consacrées
aujourd'hui à l'industrie pharmaceutique
et puis à partir de 15h45 c'est à
l'examen au sénat du projet de loi sur
le mariage pour tous vous pourrez suivre
l'intégralité de nos débats jusqu'à 19
heures bon après midi à tous